[Applause]
from victory
to defeat within weeks I am resigning as
leader of the conservative party
Liz trance's leadership has been short
but not uneventful just two days after
becoming prime minister the death of
Queen Elizabeth II was announced
politics ground to a halt as the UK
observed the morning period for
Britain's longest serving Monarch but it
was her promise of sweeping tax cuts a
pledge that won her the leadership race
that cast out on the direction she was
taking how they would be funded remained
unclear we are cutting stamp Duty that
uncertainty sent the markets into
meltdown while Millions face the cost of
living crisis the pound plunged to a
37-year low and the bank of England
intervened to protect pensions yet trust
insisted it was the right course well Mr
Speaker what we have done is we have
taken decisive action criticism followed
the honeymoon period was over
great pleasure upon her faithful you
turn her Chancellor in close Ally at the
time quasi-parteng was sent a familiar
face former foreign secretary Jeremy
Hunt replaced him in a hasty reversal
began
is clear that parts of our mini budget
went further and faster the markets were
expecting
so the way we are delivering our mission
right now has to change
but it did little to ease fears
disapproval of her handling of the
economy continued even from steadfast
allies I disagreed with the policy but
that's up to Great Britain to make that
judgment
in the end the Fallout from her first
major political announcement proved too
damaging for her and her party two-year
energy freeze gone tax-free shopping
gone economic credibility God
a second cabinet minister quit hours
later conservative MPS allege they were
bullied into backing trusts
voters lost confidence already
contending with the economic
repercussions in terms of a sort of
legacy of of trustism it's It's perhaps
the the end of of of cachism the end of
you can have your cake and eat at the
end of that kind of fantasy politics our
return to with her with her removal a
return to the real world where policy
has to be made in uh you know a
globalized economy lesson for the next
leader whose primary job will be to
restore stability and confidence in the
UK thank you Cartier Lopez Al Jazeera